you welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
it is Friday January February March I
have to count to the months it's March
15th because I'm a child you don't do
that in there Feb remarking now March 15
2019
what are you doing December December 12
obviously so sometimes you can count
back with you though December November
October dude I didn't recognize the I
just swear to God I didn't know the
month count until I was like 15 it's
tough it's I don't know why again I'm
Dyslexic you uh but I would always have
to be like God January February is so
tough mr. tough
where were you wanted these geniuses
that remembered the month I'm like a
genius
Wow way to flex on me thank you to our
sponsor today calm
Robin Hood candid and quip now we have a
lot of great material here to discuss
first of all it's ridiculous how much
great stuff we have Ethan Bradberry and
Mo Bradbury were at salt Bay's
restaurant and took a video and we got
an interview with them about the
experience hello that's incredible we've
got Logan calls a flat earther we've got
Jake Paul's new single which is just
awful we're gonna enjoy watching that
walks around in a straitjacket talking
about he's single but I come today
before you all with a heavy heart yes
such a tragedy that occurred yesterday
in New Zealand I really don't want to
get into the specifics because to be
frank and I and I always say this and I
really think this when it comes to these
two these people that do these awful
things they do it for attention they do
it for recognition they the media always
gives them copious amounts of what they
want they make it like a video game with
a high score and and what I would like
to remind everyone that the best thing
to do and situations like this is don't
don't look at his name don't look at his
pictures don't look at his video don't
look at his writing
look at his thoughts you know what I'm
saying don't even don't even think about
him the guy is nothing that's why he
that he's nothing let's keep it that way
haven't said while we were talking about
because everybody it's it's all I don't
it's obvious there was a tragedy in New
Zealand it's like it's so it's so sad
and it's so it's just so ridiculous you
guys I mean I've really been disturbed
by this just first of all remember the
victims think about the victims think
about these people that were affected by
it don't give this guy any attention he
is nothing I mean everyone in New
Zealand right now it's still a victim
because it just happened and who knows
what else does guys are planning and
it's like they everyone was locked down
and schools and they couldn't go
anywhere and couldn't talk to anyone so
it wasn't horrible yeah it was really
locked out
well it was it was a wild thing because
there was people at large yeah so nobody
really knew what was going on but and
then there's the other angle that this
guy had brought up he had said subscribe
to PewDiePie and the fact that a live
stream the whole thing live stream
Facebook live the whole stream it's just
uh it's just it's ridiculous and but the
whole thing is just such a mess honestly
and I just I I think that the best thing
we can do is support the victims donate
help how you can and don't give this guy
any attention at all that's the best way
to deter this from happening because
these people do it because they want to
be famous they want to be infamous so
starve him of that do not give him any
attention that's it that's
that's the best thing I can think to do
you know a lot of people argue about all
these huge societal issues and well
those are perfectly valid conversations
have I'm not in a place to discuss those
things the only thing that that makes
sense to me is don't give that guy any
attention if you I see his picture
online and I'm Eeva and I am repulsed
I'm like I don't want to see his [ __ ]
face I why are you even showing me his
face I don't even want it I want him to
not as soon as I heard about it on
Twitter I saw his face without even
trying to look and don't even at all
that guy is nothing why should I see his
[ __ ] face you know it's funny at any
rate it's not funny there's nothing
funny about it
so that's that's my personal take on on
how to combat these things as it on an
individual level because you know you
can debate all day about about it but
it's a tragedy and and let's not give
him any attention at all so that's it
that's my take and if you do seep you
like and if you see news outlets and if
you see people checkmarks sharing this
stuff
tell him I'm following blah commute I'm
just say hey dude I don't let's why are
you giving him attention why are you
showing me his picture right into the
because I think people are now starting
to be aware of like we need to stop I
see more people talking about it now
well I'm so happy to see that because I
really think that's a huge thing in
society we need to address because it is
always always always we fetishized these
people especially in the mainstream
media when you put on like 24 hours new
networks it's like they get so deep into
it they're like this was what he was up
to
we looked in his room and we found this
and this is where he was talking and
this is what his brother was doing and
here's pictures of him when he was a kid
it's like dude what are you doing mm-hmm
so let's not do that
I'm gonna try to move on we've got you
know can you do it you we've got a got a
entertaining show here that we've
planned and we will try to entertain you
we did remove our video yeah because
just for the timing of that was
unfreaking believable yeah yesterday we
posted a video I had we got this really
horrific hate mail that blew me away
when I read it threatening to kill me
and ela and whatever you do from a
t-series fan and I read it and I said
you're saying don't do that you can just
say don't do that we read it and said
Wallace subscribe to PewDiePie for
revenge the title the video subscribe to
PewDiePie for revenge the same freakin
day this guy that did this awful thing
says okay lads subscribe to PewDiePie
before and I'm not I'm not putting blame
on anybody I'm not trying to say
anything about anything
I just think that first of all the
timing was so tragic okay
and I think that that meme is just not
funny anymore no no there's nothing it's
it's it's all I think that it's just I
think that leaving that video up made me
uncomfortable I felt awful about it and
that I just I don't know and again I'm
not blaming PewDiePie I'm not saying I'm
just saying just forming as soon the
timing was just awful there's just
nothing there was nothing nice about
that video anymore especially the video
discussing at that and it said like they
thought it was like revenge yeah I was
like oh my god the timing on this was
just so I was blown away you know I was
just blown away I was talking with mr.
beast because he's coming to LA next
week to do the podcast and we had just
exchanged phone numbers and he called me
and I thought you were scheduled
the podcast he's like no no no like hey
man did you hear the news I was like
what are you talking about because I was
expecting his call
I just gave my phone number schedule he
says oh yes somebody he said oh this
thing just happened and he said
subscribe to PewDiePie I didn't want to
believe it at first I was just like
there's no way there's no way
it's like the worst they really man I
felt so I just feel awful about it so of
course I went and erased the video I
mean come on
and I tweeted out the video I erased the
tweet I mean come on I'm not trying to
it's just what that video is not is not
funny anymore no it's not good I felt
bad so I removed it that's it that's all
there is to it unbelievable man there's
a lot to process
I'm not making any comments about
anything you know it's too soon to even
think about anything I'm just processing
it and I'm just I am
gutted by I felt I've been feeling just
awful about it I mean it meant I
couldn't believe the timing of that
forty nine people dead right now and
they say at least they say at least 49 -
probably because a lot of people will
die injured in the hospital
yeah from their injuries yeah really
crazy day yesterday because there was
also shots in Tel Aviv the Rockets right
right or yeah the Rockets that usually
they when it reaches Tel Aviv is an
unusual event it's pretty crazy mm-hmm
and um I was just talking to my mom and
she was telling me about it she just
arrived home in the evening and she
started to hear the sirens and then she
heard like two big explosions because
they they catch their
good in air and to do not let it land
anywhere so I asked her what so what did
you do when you hear it and she was like
nothing just sitting on the couch
watching TV that's and it reminded me
like right Israel it's like yeah you
been gone dance is what it is yeah there
was a lot of or when we were living
there together there was a period where
we were having sirens Rockets were
coming does I mean dozens of times a day
for like a month and it was just the
Rockets siren everyone takes cover the
scariest is when you're walking on the
street and then the wrought-iron hits
yeah I remember Sean was walking there
was this little alley
that we used to walk to to the bus stop
and there's no cover there it's wide
open and so a rocket hit Sean or I mean
a siren hit Sean when when he was
walking to work and he just had to lay
down and like the gutter you did yeah
that's the worst out open you're like
all right well because usually you'll
take cover on like the north side of a
building or something away from the
rocket and you feel like relatively safe
there but out in the open you're just
like all right well yeah let's say a
prayer with a prayer
I think people we are people are so
charged up these days so charged up man
so I don't know I don't want to talk
about it anymore than that
there's everybody's talking about it
you'll see it everywhere on Twitter on
the news on YouTube on reddit
just hard 24-hour news I mean you know
so let's get into the entertainment yes
we recently went to the doctor
mm-hmm celebrate the life that is coming
into this earth about this news Theodore
Theodore our child our son
we checked on just one was that like two
days ago here he is you guys ready so
this little guy he's developed enough I
was asking the doctor I'm like could he
technically come out now I mean not that
I want him to tell everyone that's like
what do you planning why are you asking
I'm just curious about the you know how
kids develop I said could he technically
survive outside the womb now just out of
curiosity because I was I'm curious like
how well it developed is this little guy
inside of you and yes he could mm-hmm
he could technically survive outside the
womb now which is so crazy so there's
like a full-on baby in there so wild
here is watch this
just got a little face for sure see that
[ __ ] though that's the face in the hand
eyes mouth moving
cuz he's a little heart beating and
those are his hands on the side you see
his mouth watching that's the hand on
top of his head like a monkey look at
that fantastic isn't it is like our
doctor rolls I love that guy man it's
not a trip that's awesome it's hard to
uh it's hard to express or to understand
without being in the stitch when I fell
or at least from my perspective it's
just how miraculous yeah it is I mean
cuz you walk right oh yeah baby you know
he had a baby but that's my that's me
and ela brought that out of nothingness
and there's a little baby that's a
little mean a little you it's an elite
athlete and he's a no-tell he said he is
gonna be a freaking foo that guy's gonna
run a quick mile man it's just
incredible I can't wait to meet him yeah
so crazy but then I saw this video you
know childbirth is one just one of those
things right okay this is the funniest
[ __ ] I ever seen watch this [ __ ]
watch the dads face is the best [ __ ] I
ever seen in my life
[Music]
what did he see you know like that sound
early Bertha's the guy just took a peek
back there and he gagged he almost
sounded like you in your videos man you
think is that amazing like he just
briefly peeks and he's just like I'm out
I'd be gas and this is like a hard guy
with both chains and tattoos and [ __ ]
right what did he see man I love how
hard well I told he said I don't want
him looking at anything down there I
don't want to look now I'm gonna look
when the baby comes out that's what I
was advised to do by our friends that
have been through this themselves cuz
some people look I'm not gonna watch I
might peak but I'm not gonna like watch
I'll be there okay mm-hmm
I'll be there I'll be holding your hand
I'll be there with you like our heads
because there I imagine there's like
there's a barrier you're there or you're
there so I'm gonna be there on the face
side but you know be funny if I did that
just a father deal no I'm with me look
at her head and I peek back I'm gonna
peek but it's probably got to look super
gnarly yeah get yourself too cuz you've
just pushing you pushing you pushing and
you just feel like Williams is gonna
[ __ ] myself I'll be like either did you
just pooped I'm like no no I'm just
kidding but I heard they're real quick
about it they like know what they're
doing the nurse is like oh no that's
what I heard I don't remember where it
or that but yeah you wanna watch that
video again now speaking of children
that you guys hear about this College
Admission scandal this thing cracks me
up
it fascinates me I'm floored by it I'm
awed by it I can't get
for the story super ultra rich parents
were paying schools bribing coaches
paying off people at the SATs to take
the test for their kids or fudge the
numbers paying them insane amounts of
money one coach was estimated to have
been paid twenty five million dollars
over the course of this bribery scandal
The Dude's in like Beverly Hills in a
fifty million dollar house like I wonder
how he afford that he's just a coach
they afford that but it's not like he
was like a big he was like the coach of
like the rowing or he was like a sports
director I don't know I know college
coaches make a F load of money
mm-hm but he was not one of those people
anyway I got to start saving for
Theodore's college fund because I
figured it might cost $100,000 for like
four years five knowing our son not
calling him dumb or anything but it runs
in the family not under my watch but it
turns out I may need actually up to six
million dollars to bribe the coach which
is what some people pay it yeah and says
some parents pay it up to six million
fantastic how that's a real sucker
because some people got in for fifteen
thousand and then some suckers ended up
paying six million what that was to get
into like Harvard and Yale and those
kind of screw it more more they're like
hey you want to get into UC Santa Cruz
fifteen thousand I'll take a fifty doc
oh you want Harvard six million yeah
that makes sense
you know what I was like six million
dollars why don't you just hire a tutor
you loser just study idiot I think they
care about that Ethan so let me know
want that title Harvard yeah but like
all right so I on your way into a
country club almost so this is my
favorite part of the story that they so
these coaches were photoshopping
pictures to make them look they would
take the the head of their child and
Photoshop them onto ass
leads bodies dude how awful did those
look they got a relief yeah they haven't
been released yet but I'm so desperate
to see what those look like my goodness
but it's like part of mmm evidence we're
gonna be public maybe eventually I don't
know it's not public yet well I think
cuz it involves minors there's some it
might even be in the case and maybe just
the media isn't releasing it because of
their policy of not right give the media
that have said it give him too much
Brittany honestly the media is like a
baby was a killed and here's the
pictures of it from all angles
um one girl got this this blue online
that they have people inside the SATs
that's so crazy I don't know that you
appreciate that how I'm saying the SATs
are but so people inside boosting their
graves from a thousand which is like a
pretty shitty score it's a very shitty
score to 14 20 which is like an
incredible score understand first of all
why do parents care so much yes well why
do kids care so much and then how did
they both care about it together that
much yeah cuz like if my mom cared about
it so much I feel like I would be the
opposite I would be I don't want to do
this I think you know like as a teenager
you have to live here to appreciate how
crazy people are about college and I
think that's why we're in such a debt
crisis with college because people have
fetish sized college so much and it is
this collusion between parents and kids
like it's a it's like a heritage like my
dad how he is about UCLA I mean psycho
he's him he's ridiculous my dad went to
UCLA he still wears like a UCLA
graduation ring the guys like almost 70
years old it's like get over it dude it
is like oh my goodness gracious it's
like a huge blue ring it looks like a
high school graduation ring it's like
the guy's license plate says hates USC
because
USC is their sports rival
okay when I was a kid my dad saw
somebody with a USC license plate and he
with the whole family in the car sped in
front of him and cut him off very
dangerously on the freeway with his
whole family in the car I'm not kidding
like and I'm not exaggerating either my
mom was like Gary what are you doing
slow down and my dad just shuts down he
when he gets upset he shuts down and he
shuts down he forgets that his whole
family's in the car which apparently he
does he cares about less then showing it
to you know shoving it to this USC fan
mining is a business he literally cuts
him off super dangerous on the freeway
probably going 80 miles per hour so
there's definitely a cultural difference
that I'm because in Israel no one cares
that much about which college you go
like there's absolutely no one care
people are insane about college sports
about college life about fraternities I
mean it's it's ridiculous
so did you apply to UCLA I don't think I
did even I my grades were not good
enough I was like USC and maybe you see
Dave obviously that was disappointed
Mike didn't give a [ __ ] about what my
dad thought I didn't even entertain the
thought but my grades were not that's
what that's how I would think normally
like you know your dad is obsessed with
UCLA you'd be like [ __ ] UCLA I'm going
as far as I can from UCLA nobody has
that relationship with their parents my
brother for example went to UCLA
and they have that in common my brother
and my dad but a lot of student at
they're like I'm I'm gonna it's a status
for the parents who were like I'm gonna
get you getting into the best school
reflects as good on me
as it does on you of course well maybe
my student goes to Harvard maybe if you
actually raised a smart kid that could
get into yeah
UCLA I'm sure that would be well it's a
lot more difficult but that's great
or difficult to when they're kids that
don't deserve to go there that are
getting in because their parents bribed
somebody right
no and these are really prestigious
difficult schools to get into and so it
takes a lot of work and a lot of
dedication a lot of hard to get into
these schools which are very competitive
because of all these reasons I mentioned
before and so I think that it does make
sense and these rich these [ __ ] rich
[ __ ] suckers like there's this one
famous woman from Full House Lori
Lolan how do you say her name I don't
know Laughlin Laughlin that's a weird
one that's like Irish right heard
thought so this Lori Loughlin we poked
the picture she's in full house and she
paid five hundred thousand dollars to
bribe a coach to pretend her daughter
was Natha you guys might recognize her
now here's the crazy part her daughter
is a is a fairly large beauty guru on
YouTube a YouTube channel and she paid
five hundred thousand dollars for her
stupid talentless daughter to get into
like USC or something or some
prestigious school and I and that was
for two daughters to five hundred Oh is
a bargain so you got like a one place
bargain deal buy one get one free
there's no way that they didn't know
what both what was going on in my
opinion she says she didn't know give me
a [ __ ] break
that's my opinion but like that this
this rich super rich family colluding
together to fraud to cheat their way
basically to buy prestige and to act
like you're a good like you like that is
like so it's so messed up like how what
does that say about your outlook on the
world when a mother and daughter can
collude happily to lie to get her into a
prestigious schools they say I don't
blame the daughter at all it's all on
the parent if you ask me well she raised
the daughter even at this age it's you
are still the parent
kind of values are you teaching her
right there - yeah now that's what I
call good parenting you know and she's a
beauty guru she's like 1.6 million she
had like eight almost two million with
Sephora if you guys don't know what
Sephora is it's like this ridiculous
money-making makeup company I mean that
must have been worth like I would guess
Millions she was gonna make a product
with Sephora they dropped her like off
like a bag of dirt and and you know
she's I saw her yeah this is what
self-made it reminded me of that Kylie
Jenner self-made billionaire yes she saw
she's self-made just like Kylie Jenner
hey guys here's my $50,000 collection of
makeup products yeah self-made if she's
self-made then I'm the Pope so find them
this is like she's from full house like
you're going to jail too by the way
yeah sorry go ahead yeah I just sent the
character from Full House is going to
jail she got she went to the cops were
like hey prison time dumb dumb fraud and
she posted bail a million bucks bill but
she's harasses in hot water and her
daughter's kind of [ __ ] her she erased
all the comments or disable all the
comments and [ __ ] on her YouTube channel
I didn't know you guys I just thought
that I could get into a prestigious
culture with the 2.0 and a 1000 SAT but
imagine for her she's growing up in this
environment and probably her mom's
friends are also doing it guys I thought
I could get into Harvard with it with AC
average I had no idea the SAT I didn't
even take the SAT they just sent me a
card that said I got a 1420 had no idea
that my mom was cheating I was
home-schooled you guys what's high
school all right let's take a break
we've got a lot more to talk about
Eli appreciate that you're trying to
sympathize with her I just haven't
because I have a problem whenever
there's an adult in the situation
you gotta blame the adult no matter how
old is the girl it doesn't matter like
she's still not as old as her
dunno better here's the thing she's a
girl
who's who Oliver a lot of her friends
and stuff are working their ass off to
get into a prestigious school she sees
that you see when you're in high school
and you're applying to colleges you see
a lot of people around you getting their
heart broken and crying because they
didn't finish school in her life oh this
devil hills whatever it is in her life
the money the money only gets you in if
you're a scammer fear fraud err I'm sure
that she had a thousand peers in her
class five hundred peers whatever that's
what I had a lot of them don't get into
the College of the choice because they
got rejected you're crying you're upset
but she knew that they just paid half a
million bucks to get into what I don't
care I'm not trying to blame her I don't
care it's a funny story what do I care
I guys I got why are you all upset I got
I got DS the whole throughout high
school and I'm going to Harvard it's not
that hard she probably thought they just
checked out on our YouTube channel and
liked her and I wrote a really good
cover letter I think that's why they let
me in even though I have - they just
watched my Urban Outfitters hole and
they loved my pics of the month yeah
they liked my bikini shots I am they
must have watched my YouTube channel
when I did of a cute why I I've got a
lot of subscribers and I've got a lot of
makeup and I'm going to Harvard all
right let's take a break we'll be back
we got so much more to talk about guys
it's only funnier
and more engaging from here ela stress
is a worldwide epidemic why is this
happening life is too complicated
there's way too much stuff for us to
figure out try getting a date for
Christ's sake not you because we're
married don't get it too we're fine but
with stress and anxiety many people can
often feel exhausted during the date but
then when it's time to go to sleep guess
what you cannot fall asleep that's the
biggest curse that you can face as a
human being on this planet Earth if
worry is affecting your days and nights
it's probably gonna be affecting your
overall health - your shaving days off
your life that's why I'm proud to be
partnering with calm the number one app
to help reduce your anxiety and stress
and to help you sleep better more than
40 million people around the world have
downloaded it if you had to calm down
calm h-3 you'll get 25% off a comp
premiums subscription which includes
guided meditation on issues like anxiety
stress and focus including brand new
meditation everyday there are also sleep
stores which are bedtime stories for
adults designed to help you relax they
even have soothing music and more guys
everybody is so stressed in this planet
everything is way too complex it's
ridiculous we need calm and we need to
be calm right now HD listeners get 25%
off a comprar Miam subscription at calm
calm calm calm it's the same thing calm
calm calm calm /h straight that's C ALM
calm /h 3 get unlimited access to all of
calms content today at calm calm
/h 3 get calm and stop stressing Robin
Hood is an investing app that lets you
buy and sell stocks ETFs option Kryptos
all commission-free ela that's right
it's way too sweet of a deal while other
brokers can charge up to 10 dollars for
every trade Robin Hood doesn't charge
any Commission fees so you can trade
stocks and keep all of your profits plus
there's no account minimum deposit
needed to get started so you can start
invest
staying at any level now here's what I
love about Robin Hood they have
tutorials
it's very beginner friendly but it's
great for everybody they teach you how
to trade while you're doing it they are
these wonderful terrific tutorials that
make it very easy to learn there's no
Commission if you ever been interested
in the stock market or trading of any
kind get on to Robin Hood because this
is the place to learn as the place to do
it simple intuitive design makes it easy
for newcomers and experts alike view
easy-to-understand charts and market
data and place a trade in just four taps
of your smartphone you can also view
stock collections such as 100 most
popular with Robin Hood you can learn
how to invest in the market as you build
your portfolio discover new stocks track
your favorite companies and get custom
notifications for price moving so you
never miss the right moment to invest
here is where it gets juicy Robin has
given listeners of our podcast a free
stock like Apple Ford or sprint to help
you build your portfolio what the eff a
free stock sign me up
sign you up at h3 podcast
Robin Hood dot-com head on over to h3
podcast Robin Hood comm and get a free
stock to get you started learning and
trading right hacking today I wish so
bad the candid existed when I had a kid
because I had braces as a worst fricking
thing ever and my teeth weren't bad I
just had a couple little nubs that
needed to be pushed back and what can
did does it's cheaper it's faster and
it's invisible so you can take it out
when you eat food can you imagine the
convenience this is a revolution if you
have a smile or your teeth users there's
an imperfection others always urge you
now is the time to transform your life
candid makes a clear aligner that are
sent directly to your home and
customized specifically to straighten
your teeth the aligners fix crooked
teeth crowding / 2 protrusions and gaps
the first step is to purchase their
model and kit which will be sent to your
home so you can take first impressions
of your tea
then their network of orthodontists
review your specific case and provide
you with a 3d preview of what your
treatment will look like you can also
talk to a real person at any time they
have a beautiful gracious customer
support their treatment time it takes
about six months and it's gonna save you
thousands of dollars compared to the
traditional route and my god
I was watching Billy Eilish is that her
not once and she's about to eat a wing
and she just took out not even I she was
wearing I know it wasn't oh my god I'm
so jealous you guys you're one step away
from getting straighter whiter teeth by
the way they whiten your frickin teeth
that I mentioned that take advantage of
candidates risk free modeling kit
guaranteed plus when you use my
dedicated link candid koat.com slash age
3 you'll save 50% on your model and kit
that's candid co.com slash age 3 to get
50% off the price of your modeling kit
go to candid koat.com slash age 3 and
get that beautiful confident radiant
smile that is gonna change
everything you ever knew about what it
means to be a life on this planet earth
what more is there to say about the quip
electric toothbrush that hasn't already
been said I'm gonna restate a couple of
things if you don't know it's an
electric toothbrush at a twenty five
dollar price point it is giving you the
best clean in your mouth that you've
ever experienced it's got the best
softest bristles it tells you how long
to brush it vibrates when it tells you
to pull pull say it's going to tell you
to switch sides is gonna give you the
best clean and your mouth that you're
ever gonna get for 25 bucks
now oral hygiene is one of the most
important things on this planet Earth
I'm talking relationships I'm talking
professionally you debt is the last
thing you want to put out to the world
that you have stinky breath yellow teeth
that you don't take care of your mouth
because guess what if you don't take
care of your mouth people know you don't
take care of the rest of your life it's
at that important and I'm telling you
this is the only toothbrush that I'm
gonna use okay it's not bulky it's slick
it's a tiny vibrating tube that you
stick in your mouth what more do you
need to know than that okay here's the
deal guys and
I'm telling you it's at 25 bucks just
give it a shot you're gonna see what I'm
talking about it's freaking amazing and
also has a little tongue scraper on the
back to clean that disgusting tongue you
gotta brush your tongue people and you
by the way you also have to brush the
top of your mouth too
you got all that plaque yes you look
because that's all plaque from your
tongue gets stuck to the roof you got to
clean it all you got to clean the gums
and you got to do it with the clip
electric toothbrush now you'll find out
more
brushing tips with Ethan next week but
until then they're backed by 20,000
dental professionals it starts with 25
bucks go to get quick calm /h 3 right
now you get your first refill pack free
with an equip electric toothbrush that's
a top and a pack of a toothpaste I
believe you're gonna get for free
that's your first refill pack free at GE
t qi p comm /h 3 welcome back everybody
now we were on the topic of Lauri
Lachlan talkin Laughlin Lori Loughlin
from Full House talking with her
daughter the very one that she bribed Oh
Olivia Jade the youtuber the very one
she bribed to get this clip is from
March of this year
oh this is from August 2017 originally
so this is her just a couple yeah this
is way too good let me just let me just
clarify once again cuz this is way too
good this lady paid half a million
dollars to cheat for her daughter
to get into a school she didn't qualify
for I think it was daughters I think it
was - well then okay sure this is the
one that were in question and I looked
it up it was USC actually so USC and and
she is a beauty guru and here they are
talking about how they just watch this
is okay okay okay so this is the other
daughter I think no no this is Olivia it
says it says all her daughters
Bella and Olivia Jade oh [ __ ] the names
right there
so this is the other one but Olivia
Jade's the youtuber yeah so but editing
right listen to her talking about her
daughter's I never pushed my kids to I
always say do the best you can it's not
I'll just buy you into college you
believe this [ __ ] look at her sitting up
there like she's a model mom you're
[ __ ] suck you know I don't ever do I
never push my kids to I always say do
the best you can it's too bad I'm not
gonna interrupt you guys didn't listen
my I was never that kid ninh there
fought my husband team their dad never
we were never like at school you got to
get straight A's you know we were never
those parents give it your all do the
best you can cuz in life if you give it
your all and you do the best you can
there's that's it but that's all you can
do and that's enough in my opinion
especially with kids I think we put so
much pressure and stress on them a lot
of it is unnecessary and I think um it's
important to just have downtime free
time I never over scheduled my kids and
never I always gave them plenty of time
to just sit in their playroom and you
know use their imaginations yeah wow
what a psycho
yeah what a psycho so I love how the
daughter never says anything and it's
all about yeah that gives you a peak in
the do you believe the irony is so rich
it's so rich you could slice it with a
knife we don't want we don't push them
too far because they all you could do is
try and then we'll pay half a million
dollars to get you to USC and Photoshop
your face on an athlete it's so crazy
who's her is her husband someone famous
I think her husband is also someone
famous he's like yeah Matt Massimo he's
like it's like a fashion yeah
as I like the target ship target let me
see what he looks like
oh yeah yeah yeah mess how do you
suppose what saying that's emo
I don't y'all see how stupid I really am
um actually exact wrong he's an
executive at Lionsgate actually so you
know what's his name look it up Michael
R burns y'all you need to get your facts
straight if you're confused oh maybe
that was hope to my first husband she's
been married multiple times
Oh Massimo damn I'm sorry exactly the
point but I don't I I couldn't find the
uh how do you spell name I didn't see
anything about Matt Matt Oh Matt see mo
ma ma see mo mo SSI mo and a it's all of
the it's like targets brand mo why am I
not seeing anything
mo SSI mo can y'all just send me a link
of the picture of him I want to see what
it looks like
sure yep Massimo Giuliani so here's the
[Music]
let's get a look at this guy Oh oh yeah
look at this what a handsome couple
he's old as [ __ ] actually what the hell
weird I can't be the same that's not
okay it's here he's like damn I'd [ __ ]
this guy but then here he's like grandpa
what's up Gramps interesting are you
know he's old as hell
the youth feel that he forgot he forgot
the dreidel hair look what does that
cheap-ass hair dye called hairs for men
hairs for men that's the one we did a
video the black where I died all my hair
just for me just for men no women
allowed yeah she met yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the end of the baby foreskin
treatment this month wait what is going
on with their age are they the same age
because she does not period of aged much
and he has aged like 50 years right how
can you get me a age difference on these
guys she is 54 years old and he is 75 no
he's younger than her Wow
she's you know what she's doing she's
getting baby foreskin injection I think
so I think so
holy smokes she looks good you know it's
usually the people complained the
opposite right that the man ages
gracefully and the woman does not but in
this case I will say she that foreskin
has gone to good use dude I want to be
surprised if she was literally drinking
baby's blood or some weird crazy [ __ ]
crazy yeah
the here's the tweet from Sephora hi
there after careful review of recent
developments we have made a decision to
end the Sephora collection partnership
with Olivia George yeah effective
immediately
bro that that hurt that is like millions
do we went to Sephora once I was trying
to find beauty products you can't even
walk out of there without spending $500
it's ridiculous it's like the whole mall
can be empty but Sephora is like a party
it is there's a techno plane
it always smells like ass not actual ass
but you walk out of there like you know
when you go to a bar and everybody's
smoking and then all your clothes stink
forever so it's kind of like that it's
like this is horrible perfume yeah and
you clothes are just [ __ ] yeah yeah
and I love this story I love everything
about it
Family Values full house yeah now I
guess some of those colleges are getting
sued because the current students are
like you you devalued our to be honest
yeah yeah that's an interesting point
you know although I don't think that
college it's it was the okay so it was a
parent Lee perpetrated by bad actors
yeah but how do you defraud a school
that easily I just Photoshop the kid's
face on you know what I'm saying like
dude one coach make twenty five million
bucks that's crazy yeah by the way
here's her daughter apparently this is
her most popular video this is how she I
guess got big is that she's friends with
David direct I have no idea how now
Dobrynin that's how this is her most
popular video so I'm sure it was a huge
boost for her but here she is with her
mom John Stamos looking like he just
John stainless looking like his planes
about to go down or something look at
the face and and david dobrik i really
don't know how they match up here cut
that part by the way here's my tip as a
youtuber cut that part the part where
you're setting up the camera and talking
about it being overexposed not charming
cut it
this should be a 40 I think man these
guys they're like everything's content
like us setting up the frame is
continent all right shut all right
anyway
fascinating stuff I guess we've talked
about this enough Michael Jackson we've
talked extensively about Michael Jackson
in previous episodes and I am NOT trying
to judge up that conversation again
I only want to point out one thing
quickly that I noticed me and Eva were
at home watching
there was this absolutely infamous
documentary and from 2003 called living
with Michael Jackson and me and ela
decided to go back and watch that
documentary it was fascinating a really
terrific peek inside of Michael
Jackson's life now here it's been a
while since I mean yeah that was that
was you've been late and you let up on
the fascinating recently so yeah into
his head I definitely I pass there's no
question it's coming in hot that I found
it really fascinating it's coming in
very hot that's the way we like it so
we're watching
oh this isn't it oh yeah yeah we did
this all remix there you guys enjoy this
[Music]
[Applause]
that out to who's the perfect our lease
tables if you're out there today thank
you for sending that man that was the
credit
keep it coming man I love it so we're
watching the documentary and I'm showing
you the video only to show you that this
is theirs this is proof that this is
because I showed this to some of my
friends and they didn't believe that it
was real so here's this I took on my own
phone Michael Jackson sitting in front
of this painting okay here he is
so now you down to that you trust me and
you know that it's real
let me show you the picture itself this
is a painting he commissioned that's in
his living room and it's him naked
pretty much and a bunch of little boys
naked little boys what is going on with
this you guys you guys see that we are
seeing that yeah
so it's Michael Jackson with a bunch of
angels little boys around I guess why is
that so impossible to frame up here let
me send you on this cord Izu min and it
gets smaller explain that click on done
did I say we are killing it
oh okay so here you go so that's the
real one so what he's done is taken out
Venus I guess I don't know anything
about mythology but he's like you know
all these little boys there it's a it's
a birth giving it's a motherly thing
right so he's like let's take the mom
out and and it's about a maternal thing
but now let's put in me jacked barely
covering my dick with little naked boys
so again you're kind of missing the
point of the original Michael and it's a
little strange
we all agree it's a little strange that
he has this in his living room even
those who think he's innocent
look at this and tell me boy that's
that's that's a little strange let's
here let's very normal
[Music]
naked actually this is a little girl I
guess isn't that the main subject in
that well are you talking about the the
chair why is why am I looking at a
statue of de oak because they copied him
yeah okay but that's enough so as I said
it was a short little brief one so guys
thank you for watching our segment today
on Michael Jackson I hope you enjoyed it
that ends the conversation your effects
are too loud
but yes yes it's love our fans truly
such fun we're having such a fun time
that today a tree podcast so there you
have it
oh and then also to revisit another
terrific subject that we had spoke about
last week so as you know I'm a huge huge
fan of our Kelley's did you girl did you
have your passport did you get your
shots did you get your passport did you
get your shots girl would you like to
come back with Rob to America I said did
you get your passport Bo it's a wish oh
they do get your shine around the full
version
yeah that's what I'm bleeding up to okay
yeah this is my favorite video on that
whole goddamn internet and so what I
found was the full version leading up to
our Kelley going did you get your
passport did you get your shots girl and
so here you can kind of see a little
more context as I enjoyed it I mean I
can't get enough of this video it's
fantastic
but it's during New Year's so what you
see on one side is fireworks going on a
jubilant party perfect which is kind of
the perfect setting for our Kylie to be
like girl would you like to come back to
America so you a year in your beginning
knew exactly new country exactly
you're cold exactly
mmm
well I love that they rehearse this
there's like a bit and the backup
singers are all queued up on it let's
set it down for a second s it's like a
preacher I want to talk to you about
Jesus
oh I mean I mean I need a girlfriend
the day before I got on the plane to
come out here there's fireworks there's
a split screen for those who are
listening those fireworks going on on
the left and our Callie preaching on the
right he has like 20 girlfriends so I
don't know what he's going on about and
he doesn't allow breakups it means one
of them ran away oh yeah that exactly
and it was over something really really
silly something we should want like she
wanted to use the bathroom and I said
girl you gotta wait for the hour I said
girl I'm gonna pee on you she didn't
want me to I was like dang customer is
that come on like 15 County girl that's
old enough for me she get that broke up
with a man and they looking for somebody
else right now
yeah
[Music]
I'm so upbeat but you gotta be single we
gotta have nobody in your life that
cares about you'll notice that you're
gone how single are you girl do you have
a mom what's your relationship like
[Music]
seeing the ladies without a job or
anybody that can vouch for your
whereabouts just to know you talk to you
have a drink of something that we can
just have something that you just put a
chain on your leg have a snack
cheat at the end of the conversation at
the end of the conversation I'm gonna
want you to come back to America with me
Oh
[Applause]
hmm so you got vanishing anybody to
split the difference
[Music]
but it's so hard to get back and forth
so hard to get back before my auras over
yeah this is so epic you got me think
have to appreciate what you're seeing
right now let me think this is I like
visions legendre yeah the thing he tooks
a lot quite a bit of time he's thinking
hard on it here pumps y'all buckle up
seat belts on you got it do you have
your passport
do you shots girl would you like to come
back with Bob to America anybody missed
you if you came to America
[Music]
so much passion do you mind if I this on
you in America
[Music]
man this is the best video on the
internet and nobody can take my mind
[ __ ] it's like such a thrill to watch
it's like like one of those super
amazing songs from like a Disney movie
mmm like a really beautiful song it's a
whole new world yeah oh yeah as well
then yeah that's what I'm thinking about
a whole new world
put those chains on my legs don't you
dare close your eyes cuz I'm gonna pee
in your eyeballs did you have your
passports do you have your shots wait
how do I get them it's a hard being are
Kelly here art do I start on that note
I'm gonna bust you you missed your cue I
miss - down for anything
yeah yeah I think it's coming up I'm
gonna there we go one more metric wonder
we go there we go
everybody buckle in seats on tight ready
here we go - do you have your passport
did you get your shots girl would you
like to come back with Rob - AMERICA
AMERICA
[Music]
girl do you like this play do you like
scat play I hope you got your shots
because you can get in a faction in
America gonna lock you in my dungeon the
black room the black room now baby
let me think hard I tried to think baby
how do I get you from America for them
from Ethiopia to America and there's
only one way
[Music]
you've got to give me your passport so I
can shred it up when we arrive I've got
a sex called baby and I'd like you to
join
[Music]
yes now you're gonna be having sex with
a lot of ladies a lot of men so we gotta
check you for STDs and we got to make
sure you get your shots girl vote
let's get near the end yeah he does she
loop that was good no that was good
good planning either you want to do an
impression no I was gonna ask you to do
the face that he does America the face
is like did I just say if I said it I
[Music]
hold it for a minute oh you look so good
now honey I'm gonna need you to get on
the first flight over but have you
checked yourself for polio we don't want
none of that Ebola back home neither
girls so get that checked out yes girl
do you have HIV yes cuz that's a no I'm
sorry baby you look good though girl do
you have syphilis in your brain I'm
sorry girl that's a no for syphilis
chlamydia
that's curable let's think about it
Vidia is curable but I don't want it to
get too far now girl do you have
gonorrhea
that's curable gonorrhea is curable girl
you just take a little antibiotics girl
do you have genital herpes
that one's a little tougher to navigate
up baby I'm gonna have to pound some a
gentle herpes girl
do you have HPV well I don't know I'm
gonna pass on the HPV generally speaking
girl do you have hepatitis A through Z
yeah I'm gonna pass on the hepatitis
baby but you look good good
have a great life neat pio pio what kind
of diseases can you catch from eating
feces well you're gonna want to get a
shot against that girl what diseases can
you catch from drinking pee you're gonna
want to get shots for that baby yeah not
that I'm not that I'm saying I'm gonna
pee on you but there's a shot you know
what I'm saying a shot so get that shot
all right what I mean is I'm in love
with you so epic fireworks are going off
girls are screaming their hands are in
the air they want to come back to
America America home of the Friel in my
basement and rape my pee yeah
oh I find it interesting that everybody
is like oh yeah our Kelly
definitely is guilty but MJ oh there's
no evidence the burden there's the same
amount of our Kelly's not as likable but
am I wrong and you guys can correct me
if I'm wrong because I don't want to
speak out of turn here but that people
say oh it's just their word against
Michaels there's no actual evidence well
I guess wait our Kelly there are videos
of him when he tape yeah although he did
get he got a cord on that one yeah you
got it
I'm wearing it somehow but the girl in
the tape said it wasn't her is why oh I
see under his spell so but but doesn't
that correlate it's like why would you
lie about that everyone okay you know
what let's not get into this yeah my
whole YouTube page is just my accent
video it's fascinating
I walk it last week we did so much
research yeah no we didn't do any
research I'm in the comments we just
watched a documentary I'm still in the
research because it's just my whole feed
and I'm down I'm watching it I'm
watching all these Michael Jackson stuff
I find it and I find it an endlessly
fascinating good did you get your shots
that's it's that not romantic sorry if
that's not romantic I don't know what is
do you have your passport did you get
your shots okay yeah everyone's like no
no I was just thinking to herself
we don't have headphones on mm-hmm and
we have no idea what it sounds like
oh I sound ball like music well you have
the chat open what are they saying there
they're just obsessed with shredder
right now to be on there's no demanding
shredder cam it's coming it's in the
world shredder doesn't come with us
office anymore he's just he started to
get more restless when we bring out he's
restless he's a young lad he's got a lot
of energy still got his balls so he just
he's got like a lot of testosterone he's
got a lot of energy I mean he
he's the sweetest soul that ever graced
this planet I love him he is the light
of my life he's my heart my soul like
everything yep I consider him my son my
firstborn son to be frank he didn't get
his shots he did get his shots your
passport
no no but he did yeah I mean what's time
we should bring him though yeah yeah
that'd be fun
no but we have people like with him my
mom goes and takes in park we have a we
have a someone's there where now yeah
I'm telling you it's ridiculous
guys did you know that Shaq is in every
freaking commercial this is not a
conspiracy I've been watching television
with ELA I've been watching a lot of
stupid crap like shark tank and well
shark tank come on but let me say that
we don't watch a lot of television no
and keep that in mind you're dead to me
every time we see commercials we see
Shaq like every single time I was
thinking of making a tweet I was like is
it just me or Shaq in every other
commercial on television and so I says
okay we'll have definitely seen him in a
Gold Bond commercial definitely see him
in a Carnival cruise commercial I've
definitely seen him in an icy hot
commercial I says to the guys in back
can you guys go find every recent and
I'm just talking about like recent this
is stuff that's on television right now
I'm not talking about historical but
these Danone so we put together this
mega compilation of all the commercials
Shaq is in recent memory this guy is in
every commercial on television why is it
is he just cheap is he easy to get ahold
of I don't think it's - yeah Shaq's rich
as hell but I guess he's like everybody
knows Shaq and he's available he's like
I'll do a commercial for [ __ ]
anything I think it's just that people
love him so much that they'll actually
buy whatever is telling them to but it's
got to be given a good deal let's watch
this compilation yeah
oh it's meted yeah here we go so I'm
sure I wake up cool but this keeps the
Gold Bond speak rain JC penney Bennett I
mean he has multiple like ads with each
of these companies different ads the I
just pulled one I know he's in several
Carnival Cruise General and everyone
knows Shaq as a Basketball Hall of Famer
but I bet you didn't know where karate
masters Buick I know you don't drive a
Buick Shaq does not drive a Buick and he
does and he's definitely not insured by
the general I'll tell you that I never
understood general insurance it's like
the shittiest CGI general telling me to
get his car insurance
why do all insurance companies have like
a weird CGI it's a really good
observation you're right I think Israel
that I was like a parent
what the eff is going on there it's not
coming a conspiracy document about that
but general by far has the absolute
worst one the general looks just I've
been dumbfounded by that for a long time
Shaktar if Shaq drives a Buick
then if Shaq drives a Buick
then our Kelly's innocent Wow
if Shaq drives a Buick then the Pope
shits in his hat and then eats it
traffic to graphic just a lot of poke
comparisons I like because I like big
okay if the thing does the Pope [ __ ] in
the woods yes I love that because it's
just so fine
well I guess the original saying is if
some so-and-so that I'm the pulp alright
but then I like does so you say oh are
you going to move stay does the Pope
[ __ ] in the woods it's like I don't know
probably not but in my case yes at fatik
yes does the Pope [ __ ] in his own mouth
tub girl style yes boy I don't know
where I'm going with this but Shaq
doesn't own a good guarantee that I
guarantee that I see hot dance is a lot
like beer commercial like what the hell
like for real a beer commercial I mean
what what if we could get him in a Teddy
fresh commercial oh my god hi I'm Jack
but what size fuzzy where we can't fit
him we'd have to make it he's got to be
like six XL or something
hi I'm Shaq and this is me and this is
my friend teddy bear if you have to be
with some his commercials are always
like invariably corny hi I'm Jack and
this is somehow charming at the same
time I shall never like like the bad
kind of cringe it's not the Shaq rules
I love shack it's not like Matthew
McConaughey yeah because Matthew
McConaughey it's not a self-awareness
it's like he's trying to be so [ __ ]
cool mm-hmm that's literally what he
does and his uh Lincoln commercial he
goes and then there's one where he says
I've never seen the girl goes I've never
seen that before and he goes uh he
combines I have into one grunt and it
was oh look at this vodka this is not a
joke
yeah this vodka there's those LCD LED
screens
you can customize a message on it like
who [ __ ] cares the bottom of this is
it's the award-winning Medea vodka from
Holland with the world's only personal
programmable LED display on the bottle
ring commercial friend of the show great
product love ring I don't know why
shekar's blowing on his kid's ear though
but I mean cheeky there being but he's
in a ring commercial on this is I
couldn't figure out what this one was
he's sniffing soap with Kendrick Lamar
it's American Express we found out I was
like men there's always soap can afford
to pay these guys American Express they
got big money and then this one was
vitamin water we also couldn't tell I'm
sure we just scratched the surface too
but like now that you know go watch
television and you'll see the Shaq is an
every other freaking commercial when I
was putting that together I just had to
stop at a certain point because it it
could have been like an hour-long coffee
if we did like every commercial I mean
I'm sure I'm pretty sure he works for
every brand I guess he doesn't have a
exclusivity clause it's almost like this
is his career no yes no he does a lot
Chuck he's a he's a yeah he's an
entrepreneur right yeah he's a DJ he's
an entrepreneur he's a DJ he's funny
yeah I love shack and I love that
picture of him with his girlfriend I
know we showed it before but it's fans
phenomenal I'm gonna pull it up again I
don't give a [ __ ] if you guys already
saw it I like Cameron Kendrick hey
that's true Shaq and and girlfriend
y'all I know I've talked to others
before but I [ __ ] love it so don't
complain it's just as good it's just as
good as the our Kelly song so I'll
expect to hear that hear what that looks
like in the bedroom hmm oh she must be a
dude I mean my god his dick is probably
the size of her whole thigh
there's no way not to think that you
can't call me oh you're a perv like how
else think about anything else what is
the size of her thigh oh man she a shack
must have a challenging existence
because he's so tall he's so huge I
think that tall is cool to a point you
know but the guys like the guys like how
tall is Shaq
you guys look it up I think he's 7 1
that's that's ridiculous I mean that's
sick the world is not made for people
that tall nope
and neither are women dance imagine god
how do they even dam like a a 7 1 324
pounds it's a big dude how much you
weigh 324 goddamn what is that light
that must be like what do you think
about that ela do you have the same
thought I do at least definitely crossed
my mind it crossed your mind yeah not
gonna rely on that that's good I don't
want you to I want you to be why do you
think his pants are so long he's got
like weirdly long pants you know why cuz
those are cuz those are those are just
long pants for normal dudes that's all I
can find Jesus Christ dude
yeah there you have it oh man I closed
my document what a dweeb um how's
everybody doing back there in talked to
me and talked to me I don't like when
you get so quiet and I want to hear more
from you we got a cameras for everybody
to write look at this they got a camera
huh I'm good there he is
comes that beautiful baby boy house
that's it we can switch back to no no no
keep it on Ian don't switch back
don't switch back I see me I don't want
any ammonia in can weasel
we got Zack captive now it's stopped I
will get to Zack why are you so
embarrassed why are you so shot you
wanted to be a stand-up comedian at one
point in your life so why you so why do
you why you so camera verse well that
career clearly failed yeah but you never
really I feel like you tell me about uh
I mean how many times did you do
stand-up maybe like seven or eight not
that many that's pretty good if up quick
the last time I did it was really
embarrassing tell me about it I want to
know now
yeah well I had this gag planned and it
just kind of fell apart and that was the
last time talk come on
don't stop - stop with the shortness we
are all interested we all want to know
what happened I'm like trying to switch
and talk oh maybe I see just leave it on
you I'll make it easier okay well I had
this idea plan where you know people
will like when they're giving a speech
or something and they forget the words
so they'll write on their hand like a
little note to reveal a thing so I did
that and I was gonna go up and kind of
act like I was forgetting my joke mm-hmm
and then check my hand and then keep
forgetting my joke and I wrote all over
my entire body like wow yeah so it was
live it to the bit right there wait wait
hold on what it's all over the body mean
did you become the joke cause you
actually forgot oh wait hold on you huh
so he was all over your arms all over
your face like what are we talking about
it was all over both of my arms and my
entire torso this long joke and so I was
gonna start like checking my hand
and then slowly pull up and okay and
then I was gonna keep going reading this
entire joke off my body and then it was
gonna end with I start to unbutton my
pants and then go oh it's not that funny
and then leave well so that was a joke
it's a long dumb gag so how long were
you on stage well here's the thing I
wrote this I went and bought markers and
I wrote like a thing all over my body I
have a photo of it somewhere and then I
went to this comedy open mic and it was
in this tiny little room and it was so
hot in there like I stepped in I was
talking to that guy next to me I'm like
is it hot in here is it just mean it's
like really warm he's like it's not that
bad but I started sweating and so I went
I was getting close to going up and then
I I was like two away and then I went to
the bathroom just to check and my entire
body was just blue ink so that is
actually like you said the joke became
super meta yeah so then I got paper
towels and like the trashcan was just
filled with like blue ink and alien got
shot in there and then I
I had to leave I had no gel you didn't
even go on stage no because it melted
then oh my there were no legible words
someone did you just bounce before they
even called you on yeah I ran out and
that was the last time yeah that's when
I retired that's not a bad attempt I
thought you were gonna be publicly
humiliated but you oh no it would it I
got out of there before that could
happen and did you ever have a good
experience on stage yeah I had a couple
all right got a couple laughs do you
remember what are some jokes you wrote
that you thought why not going down this
ant God everybody I'm guarantee
everybody wants to hear one of your joke
you should try um PowerPoint stand-up
comedy that's not about oh yeah you
already have a few fans you could take
pictures of your body with the joke
written on
you on a PowerPoint slide be like here
let me I wrote the joke on myself I'm
not a I'm not the stand-up comedian all
right Ian you're being too coy about all
this I just give me a job I want to hear
one of your jokes you know that no no no
you owe me that I don't think I do
[Laughter]
does he owe me that no oh really that's
hard to tell a joke like that on the
spot well I'm okay
an elephant and a monkey this is his big
shot
he's got the stage and he's there you
know I'm saying like this is your big
shot this could be the beginning of a
beautiful thing for you again I'm
retired I'm out of this game I got a
piece so bad all right Zach how are you
know me that's a soundboard I didn't say
that all right no that was you Zach
Howell how how's that I'm doing very
well
all right how are you I'm fine man I'm
here in the I'm here in the show
you're my garage dan is doing great as
always we got cams on every one back
there look at us we're so official
aren't we Wow we've got a pretty
complicated rig back there hey Dan it's
uh we keep leveling up yeah we got how
many cameras we got one two three four
and now we have four and back there
right yeah actually five in there right
or we we can do five in there yeah
you're right here we have a nine camera
rig going right now livestream uh yeah I
mean we're not using every camera right
now but potentially potentially yes
that's a pretty high level style you're
cool what [ __ ] killing it dude
I don't think anyone in the game has
nine cameras I mean I'm not gonna say
that we make that doesn't mean anything
about the quality of our content
we're probably number one that should be
our thing but most most cameras in the
game
[Laughter]
and think about I'm not gonna press you
anymore but I love to just kind of
mm-hmm humiliate me
know who's I'm not I'm just giving you
your big break mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah
sure all right
what else we got here today thank you
guys for checking in I would just like
to check in on the team back there good
people great people love them all really
terrific zach is about to go off to
college Zach did your parents bribe
bribe anybody no well you're not getting
in but there's kind of ways around it
like you can write a check for a
donation to the school and it doesn't
necessarily mean your kid will get in
but it's just like a wink-wink donate
did they do that no no no people do
though yeah I know some people that have
done that I thought you were gonna be
like there's other ways to get around it
like studying but I got shitty SAT
scores but what's your SAT score do you
mind I know if it's very private cuz
people no no this was like two years
I'll tell you what I got on my SAT
what'd you get well let's start with
Zach wait SAT it's different in Israel
SAT is like you take it it's a score to
assess like kind of how good you you're
well educated you are simply yeah so we
do have something done in Israel but why
did you need to do it for college or
just use it as a super sport yeah I
guess cuz I study art I don't need to
hey you have to go there where every
college hmm yeah there's another one too
what's the other one that the AC do is
it's a CT does everyone comfortable
sharing their scores
I didn't take the SAT [ __ ] that it's
awful by the way it's so brutal [ __ ]
I took the like practice one when I
still had delusions that I would get
into college and I did pretty well on
that one actually I don't remember the
score but it was decent but uh but yeah
I mean my grades and high school were
awful so I knew the thing is like the
kids who get insanely good grades have
like SAT prep courses and they study
their ass off yeah it's you know my
score I got like eight okay
I um SAT I got like a 1280 you didn't
prepare though no not that before the
change like when the MEC because it used
to be the max was 1600 that's what it
was 1800 it's like much the max is much
higher now oh I didn't know that it was
1600 was a perfect score right so 1280
was okay if you didn't do it prep I like
to tell myself you know that if I
prepped I would have got a that I'm much
smarter than then that reflects is
basically the story and Zach anyone else
want to compare you did a way better
than I did for real what you get well I
took it the first time and I got a 10:30
hmm and then I did like this tutoring
study program and I want my money this
is why but I I I'd be very well in
school right now that's why I went to a
community college and hopefully
transferring you're a great student I
think I I think IQ tests and an essay
it's all [ __ ] IQ test it's such
[ __ ] it is beyond [ __ ] I'll
never take IQ test because there's only
English and math right yeah I don't
actually test any other like science or
history or anything no it's all yeah
it's like logic right well okay the SAT
is that's right it's written so you two
like blood like reading comprehension
tests and then you have to write an
essay too and then they also test you on
math but it's all it's like algebra up
to calculus so it gets really
challenging if you don't know the math
yeah
so yeah it's reading writing and math so
and then and then the other one the
what's the name of the other one easy do
the a CT test you with like history and
[ __ ] Lions science history actually it
did better on that one I'm the opposite
I'm really bad with history but I'm good
with math and that kinda stuff
your numbers genius dude you remember
everything don't remember anything now
though yeah what happened when I met
unless you remembered everything and I
still like think that you remember
everything I'm like you know what's the
number no I do remember stuff but I mean
I don't remember anything from my
college a bra anymore from school
algebra well I was just like not you I
mean like the the complicated
Pythagorean theorem yeah
oh my god college is so annoying dude
it's the prep work is the most annoying
part I'm so glad that I'm not I still
have nightmares that I wake up and I'm
in college and like I have like to write
an essay it was the worst it's the worst
I hate school and I did five years at
Santa Cruz why did I do that I can't say
that I have this kind of nightmares
anymore I still do but don't you agree
that school is like the worst it's the
best part about being in those that you
don't have to go to [ __ ] school one
of the only good things about me
although work sucks ass even more
I'd like a normal job I kind of like
college yeah but you're could your
college was so bohemian all you did was
like paint and do sculptures and [ __ ]
exactly so I don't have your experience
but I and we did have some like more
theoretical classes but they were
interesting my experience smart but I
was like second I was like but you guys
do it at a different age too
and I think that makes a difference you
that's a very good place in Israel you
go to the army first you get all the
partying out of your system like the
teenager craziness and I went to college
when I was like 22 mm-hmm kind of
already more mature that's a really good
point
I'm not maturity levels from 18 to 22 or
different and then at that point also
you you really go because you want to do
this and not because you don't have to
kind of
mmm sorry it's a different state of mind
thing is I was like borderline suicidal
in college because of my anxiety so yeah
that made it way worse but hey that's it
yeah yeah how about that Shack huh but
damn do you guys apply what you learned
in college to your career today [ __ ] no
the college was importantly literally
zero while college was is a great place
to mature to learn to interact with
people to manage your life and stuff
like that but it's also really not
because actually just being cast into
the real world and being forced to get a
job and pay your own rent and pay your
own utility bills is a way better learnt
probably like you know yeah cause she's
just coddling kids to do like delaying
real-life opportunities I did not have
the own thing
I was forced into a video art class that
I was never gonna take and that kind of
led us into making videos and into
YouTube well there you go the whole
avenue that we would have never taken I
can confidently say that if you did not
be forced to take that video our class
almost certainly we would not be
entertainers I I never shot a video
before that class I never go go to
college kids I don't know that I can
recommend college though because yeah
it's like um such a trap it really has
become such a trap I think if you are
super if you know exactly what you want
to do if you're like I definitely want
to be a doctor I definitely want to be a
physicist I definitely want to do
whatever it is and college is the next
logical path then it makes a lot of
sense and you should definitely go do it
but if you're like um I don't really
know what I want to do but I know that
I'm probably supposed to go to college
and I'll figure it out there that's when
I think you should take a second thought
and think about if there's other
opportunities or other because in a lot
of cases if you just go get a [ __ ]
job doing anything save up some money
think about your life mature a little
bit
because when you go to college unless
your parents pay for it you're gonna
come out with a lot of [ __ ] debt and
a degree that's not gonna help you most
likely get a job especially if you do
arts like I did if you do a creative
[ __ ] like I did I mean my god
I studied creative writing for Christ's
sake for five years if I just got a job
and then saved up money and then did
writing as a passion in my free time I
would have been yeah I mean technically
you'd be way better off but it's a lot
about networking and meeting people it's
so hard to know I'm definitely
conflicted on yeah what I would
recommend someone cuz you do you do
learn stuff about even if you have to
write an essay about something you'll
never have to know again just having to
write an essay is something that
develops you absolutely but I can say
pretty much everyone I studied with in
my class and art they are I still see
them like on Facebook looking for a job
cuz that's the reality goodbye that's
just nothing really came of it it's
really hard I mean we were super lucky
that basically from my my from my degree
I was able to get a job in Israel in
America nobody gives a [ __ ] but in
Israel actually was some credibility but
same with me a lot of my friends who
went to college it's like you know
they're waiting tables and it's not
their fault they're smart hard-working
dedicated mature people but the problem
is that a college degree does not get
you what if used to and a lot of our
parents push us into going to college
because that's the next logical step
because when they were kids you would go
to college and you come out and you get
a $50,000 per year job right out of
college but sadly that's not the case
anymore and student debt has now become
the biggest pool of debt in the country
and student that unlike other debts is
not forgivable through bankruptcy so you
are you are going to be haunted by this
debt guys
forever potentially I can't really
understand that whole part because what
I'm used to is so different it's it's
really affordable in Israel it's like
$2,500 for a year oh Jesus yeah so if
you just have a part-time job or
something you can pay it by yourself
that's what I did the problem with a lot
of schools like and so I went to UC
Santa Cruz so it cost $20,000 for or
maybe it was like 15 for tuition alone
per year but then let's say you're like
I'm gonna get a job and I'm gonna pay
for it myself first of all if you want
to get straight A's that's there's no
[ __ ] way to hold a full-time job and
to do all the work where to get straight
A's
I was a shitty student so I could hold
down a part-time job but here's the
other problem there were so many people
looking for work in Santa Cruz because
there was this huge university there I
remember me and ela once went to a
yogurt shop to get an application and
the girls like I can give you an
application but honestly there's really
no point because I have a stack of about
50 people that already gave me an
application to work here making like you
know minimum wage make it six bucks an
hour so the the possibility of actually
working off a meaningful debt while in
school is laughably ridiculous it's it's
utterly ridiculous the notion that you
can work off your student debt while in
school it's just so mm-hmm
it's a fantasy it's a pure fantasy
imagine working at a yogurt shop making
six dollars an hour and trying to pay
off so and then because you can't pay to
afford yourself you have to take a loan
out for your cost of living you have to
take a loan out for your rent for your
food for everything so you're gonna end
up spending $30,000 plus per year
because you have to pay for your school
your food your living expenses because
you there's no freaking way and then
whenever these colleges are because
they're so big and inflates the real
estate and inflates all the prices so a
place like Santa Cruz before the UC
there you probably get a nice apartment
for like $500 a month
mean ELA we're paying this was 10 plus
years ago now we were
paying like 1500 bucks to share a house
and we shared a room 100 maybe 900 but
for a room oh I thought we're paying
over a thousand mm-hmm that's after
somebody came and slept on our couch to
reduce our rent isn't it I think we were
paying like two what we were paying over
a thousand we were sharing a room and
then we had some dudes sleeping on our
couch to help offset the cost you know
because there's so many people so it's
it's really a vicious cycle it's just so
brutal man
it's so brutal and these mother [ __ ]
loan [ __ ] that are backed by the
government I had a government-backed
loan at 11% the government gave me a
loan for my education at 11% that's like
illegal with like uh dude that is so
high 11 percent and then my low ones
were 6% do you know how much interest I
get on my on my savings account 0.02 so
who's making money I'm not making money
from the end like what is going on why
am I not making interest in my savings
account and then these loan people are
pet charging me 11% are you [ __ ]
kidding me dude for student loans it's
higher for student loans than any other
loans excluding like predatory like
payday loans I really hope that changes
here someday
dude I think this country is is
approaching a colossal crisis of a bunch
of young people with trillion over
trillion dollars of student debt that
they cannot get rid of with super high
interest rates that they are just gonna
be absolutely crushed I mean there's a
whole generation of kids are gonna be
[ __ ] crushed just look like that's
one 1.5 trillion plus now is the the
total student debt past credit card past
mortgage past car loans
right damn you see that you you
corroborate that
as far as amount of GERD - how much
total debt yeah let me let me see if I
can find a chart got lots of charts here
so I I mean I got I got fantastically
lucky to be able to being able to
support myself I had student debt that I
was fantastically fortunate to be able
to pay off when we were in Israel we
were working immediately the first year
in Israel we were both like let's just
get rid of this debt because I hate
knowing that I have any debt I had about
yours but I well let me just tell you
about ela I had twenty-two thousand
dollars of student debt and we weren't
married at the time we weren't even
thinking about marriage at a time we
were committed to each other though but
ela we were both working and ela was
[ __ ] pulling in her money to pay off
my student debt yeah that's a real one
but then we paid it up that goes that
was amazing I pay mine off in I think
three months
I'm almost there oh you're almost done
with yours dad yes sir
we should how much debt did you have it
honestly very low compared to what a lot
of people have I think when a when it's
the initial amount was like 25 okay well
yeah I mean that's a lot I mean yeah
it's people healthier though yeah people
have way more ya know what was your
interest rate do remember I think it was
around the same I think that that's is
that below your one day and they take
advantage of the fact that kids don't
understand anything I find a they don't
teach it in high school so you know me
it was like I didn't know that that was
exactly I don't know I didn't even look
at this [ __ ] I was like I need the money
so what do I have um boom oh and then
years later I'm like eleven percent what
it's totally nuts so I feel my heart
really goes out to our generation and
the generation
below us that are like seriously because
I'm thinking like at this point and at
least at our age like reaching the 30s
mm-hmm
you want to start thinking about buying
a house in like Oh give me a break for
most people that's well before we
started having the absolute fortune of
making a really good living doing what
we're doing now the thought of buying a
house was like I might as well just win
the lottery
yeah it was just like what buy a house
I've got a thousand dollars in my bank
account yeah
Wow I live in LA you know like you
trying to think like wait so how much
just a down payment because I have like
okay no this is what you do when you
want to buy a house you're like okay so
if I keep saving at my current thing and
if I get a raise and everything's going
great if I just keep saving for another
30 years I'll be able to put a down
payment and then I'll have the mortgage
so by the time on 85 I should be able to
pay off my mortgage yeah I can't wait
for someone to make a real change here
specifically here in America like health
care is insanely expensive and college
yeah they get you on all sides the
college one is is super predatory
because I mean education well and also I
really do think that these universities
and schools need to be there their
pricing needs to be looked at because
the way they priced the education like
if you look at the trend of prices from
like that 80s like my dad went to UCLA
and he paid like he pay like a couple
hundred bucks for a class yeah same with
my dad he went to UC San Diego filled
out like a free ride yeah my dad he
wants it you got a graduates or not a
great he got a bachelor's degree from
UCLA and he worked paid his whole way
through it mmm came out without that had
a degree I mean it's it's just not why
is that not possible anymore things
didn't change
shit's America the economy's stronger
than it's ever been we have more money
and wealth in this country than we ever
did before
so what's why has that why is that still
not possible I don't get it I don't
understand but if you look at the trend
of the prices from colleges it's gone up
like ten thousand percent what's changed
administrators get paid a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ton more that's for sure so I don't know
I don't know the college is the right
choice because unfortunately it's just a
racket at this point it's hard because
it's such a great thing it is such a
great experience but it's it's come to
the point where you have to really weigh
the pros and cons I wish there was less
common but you really have to weigh them
because there's a way through many cons
now and that's just the reality it's
really it's just rich kids at college
now kind of like I knew a girl from my
high school who went to the same
colleges mean she was an amazing student
she worked her ass off she got us even a
scholarship she was came from a poor
family and she was working full-time to
pay for college at the same time because
she was broke mm-hm and she dropped out
because it was too stressful for her I
remember I used to see her occasionally
and say hi how are you and she was like
she was just like out of her mind and
eventually she'd just dropped out
because she was like I can't I just
can't do all this I think she just had
to break them but I'd in my college days
of all the hundreds of people I knew I
didn't know anyone that worked full-time
I bear most of the people didn't even
work at all probably like 90% even have
a job so the parents are just paying for
loans yeah
Duncan come come come come come
do you have your good grades do you have
your SATs girl would you like to get a
loan from FAFSA hit me started over good
girl
dee do you have your SATs do you have
your good grades girl would you like to
get a loan from FAFSA FAFSA 11% ooh
you'll be paying me back for life girl
do you like getting your income deducted
by 5th okay you could end it get the
idea
Jake Paul guys Jake Paul's back with a
[ __ ] spicy new single all right the
topic of the puck yeah we took in a card
to the title I forgot yeah I know
so Jake Paul's out with a new single
it's everyday bro
this one's called I'm single I guess he
just broke up with his girlfriend and
he's ready to [ __ ] this is pretty much
just an invitation for people on
Instagram to send him titty shots I'm
single and my demons are open in other
words that's the alt title let's watch
and that jacket is really douchey dyke
and well that jacket is really bro it's
not it's like you're in a straitjacket
really what does that Matthew
McConaughey do a car commercial any day
[Music]
the kid boxes Fox do you really expect
me believe you walk around with that
jacket
what is that Jackie deal what's your
take on that as a fashion designer I
think it could look cool on someone else
oh really okay you liked it he's a punk
rock guy hey did you hear that
well we know who you are
[ __ ] it listen he goes Champa yes that
hypnosis this outfit you don't like no I
don't like anything cuz the way he wears
it is so douchey bro I feel farm from
Ohio dude it's like an old war the fanny
pack where are you going right now I
love Hays like dude I'm just a good old
boy on the farm with my Mustang from the
60s but also I'm wearing supreme an
off-white fanny pack a vehemence hoodie
just a good old boy with a $10,000
outfit on there Auto Tunes [ __ ] I
always imagined the auto-tune machine
like smoking and shooting sparks we're
gonna overdrive like the war pack it's
time to do this thing that like a lot of
rappers will do and it's it's the thing
that you see a lot of people do today
rappers like they kind of like sing not
trying to sing like it's kind of like no
effort right but its own I mean they
pull
it off but check fault can't do it and
it's just like oh it just sounds so bad
well that's just your opinion because I
think he has a beautiful voice I sorry I
it says I'm down here at the bottom and
sanity Ward he's ripping someone off but
it's a style you're right it's he's
trying to do like it's like he's trying
to do a post Malone thing or something
but it's like slow do it no but it's you
know not Jake Paul no but he single did
imagine being attracted to Jake Paul
it's imagine the heads face would have
to be in the one date Jake Paul it's
like MattyB
it's kind of got a MattyB vibe and it's
also for like a eight-year-old girl
audience like I'm out of my mind
I almost produced by Patrice Wilson I
want to say I'm saying when in fortress
verse yo my boy Jake yo Patrice Wilson
on the school bus it's 3 o'clock time
for school to get out I'm right behind
this car with the cute girl yeah he
always raps about little girls and [ __ ]
like from Rebecca Black
y'all remember his first from that
should I pull that up wow that's uh
that's a throwback let me pull it up
real fast y'all gotta see it Rebecca
Black Friday you all got to see this
[ __ ] at bay
hey I know exactly where it is I've seen
it so many times you guys this is what
this video is missing is a Patrice
Wilson solo RB Rebecca Black so chillin
in the front seat and the back side I'm
driving cool in fast lane switching
lanes with a car by my side Oh mom come
on
it's school bus is Friday we gone and
have some fun come on y'all
dude that's a fire burst sorry haters
what happened to Patrice it's like it
was kind of blowing up and he was huge
well I'll tell you what happened he
[ __ ] took it too damn far with
houston gold
that's like saying what happened to dark
Bishop it's like he [ __ ] him my kids
man this guy went down the Pope's like
right-hand man
the treasure of the I'm just saying he
took it too far with Allison gold you
got her in like a little bikini and [ __ ]
yeah like dude how do you go from Friday
to crank it crank it yeah I know
let me watch this first thing cuz it's
so fried it's so [ __ ] dope let's
impress I like I want to go on man the
Catholic Church is a messed up place
dude I'm not gonna back down from saying
that is I just find it's not good there
right now I know okay well I already you
know I've already been there but all
I'll say is this you look is the
treasure of the of the Vatican he was
like number three yeah went down hard
for you know what yeah damn that's not
systematic at all [ __ ] me right next
on the backside I'm private fool in
Fastlane switching that's it what a B we
gonna have some fun yeah by the way he's
following a school bus at night bro why
are you following a school bus I forgot
just how ledge increases the ledge at
any rate back to the point here he's
missing a Patrice Solo
[Music]
you can't even write it like he does
know I'm behind the bar serving up kids
that'll wait like how do you even like
what happened is Patrice is the waiter
and he comes with a milkshake and he's
like yo you're single you're single you
got to have fun you got to look out for
number one but make sure that when you
put roofies in that smoothie you got to
put it in the tasteless the odorless
kind Kidz Bop
hoping going so bad I love that all the
sudden all these shits here youtubers
think they're rappers it's so a
transparent it's like I don't know if
it's a commentary itself on the music
industry at this point but it's like I
can bet my life on that
Jake Paul has no musical talent you're
gonna need to bet ok I'm not betting on
anything
I think think we have evidence ok but so
like all of these guys it's an epidemic
and they're like oh I'm gonna be a
musician I'm gonna be a rapper it's like
is that really that that a barrier
barrier for entry it's like you don't
need to be a singer you don't need to be
able to play anything you think you
don't even need to be able to rap really
and but to hear you have it I mean it's
got 8 million views and people go and
watch him perform this [ __ ] alive I mean
they're kids granted but how is he
touring can we go to a Jake Paul concert
yes we should go you go I'll go report
back yeah bro are you serious going I'll
go to a jig Pole I'll go with you you
three go and take video they're gonna
wonder why your aunt can do a stand-up
routine I'll get I'll get you a book
you'll and and we'll get excommunicated
from the car yeah and what you can do
your Smurf routine I imagine you did
blue markers all over yourself and he
look like a smurf I was all rubbed out
[Music]
pretty high budget videos oh well shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys know you can do this speed 25%
are you a hacker dude well part of the
elite hacker group known to miss them go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Jake balls sign papers and [ __ ] back
there like use the president I'm I'm the
Pope and bathtub like tub girl [ __ ]
projectile diarrhea into my mouth you
know internet shock image of a girl
having projectile diarrhea into her own
face what Arlie I'm still don't know if
it's real or not but I think it's real I
don't studied it carefully it's cuz it's
got a crazy arc yeah it's it's yeah so
it's no goat see but just imagine the
Pope doing that though and it's Pope
outfit yeah
broken it's basically like one song
before making it do you have your
passport did you get your shot song
right because it's like an invitation to
all these girls yeah are you acting are
you 16 in some states 15 in some states
I heard it's 15 and Alabama I'll be
there next week what's the look what's
the lowest legal age of consent in the
States
I know some states go really like it's
16 in some you know are you six in are
you 18 I'm saying go now yeah Logan man
this is like a thrill throwback we're
talking about the Paul Brothers yo what
the [ __ ] I just looked it up it's 12 in
some place I'm kidding no no no where is
no oh that's in that's in Mexico it's 12
in Mexico in some states Mexican states
have a primary age of consent which can
be low as low as 12 weeks oh that is so
messed that is not lowest in the US is
16 hmm Matt dude you cannot consent as a
12 year old yeah what well that's not an
age of consent it's like the age of like
watching cartoons by yourself yeah
exactly that's a horrifying that is
horrifying
your honor she did give me her
permission yeah this is a real throwback
forgive him for talking about the Paul
brothers but you know what sometimes you
just got to get in the mud so here's I
thought this is Logan Paul's trailer for
the Flat Earth and and so first of all
it's so cringy because it's so much
trying so hard to be Shane and you
always see like one person break out
with something really original like
Shane with his
Canaries and then all of a sudden
everybody's a documentarian yeah
suddenly Logan Paul is the new
documentarian
suddenly he's a hip-hop artist and a
documentarian and it's it's edited so
overly dramatic and all he did was like
load to a flat earth convention like
it's just not that serious
so here enjoy this to the Canadian
series but even crazier why does his
voice sound like the intro to a Disney
show and but even crazier you notice he
said he brought up conspiracy theories
and then the first clip is about global
warming it did yeah you're right
well it said okay how much grease
we've all heard them someone's saying
global warming is a hoax back to maybe
the president knows weird the pitch
shift I think you're right
but even crazier five right here is my
mom and dad that run a science lab in
their basement that's like where it's
going but even crazier did my big
brother who's also a fairy this is my
crazy wife people that actually believe
that bro this maverick it kills Matt
he's got like a super cinematic looking
maverick bird that's supposed to be like
Lionsgate or some [ __ ] and it looks so
bad
okay bro really you're gonna hit me with
a long shot of you're like seven million
dollar estate what is that good to do
with anything he's establishing the
setting Neela
it just so offices a drone shot of his
he of his mansion but nothing happens in
his house does it bro he's establishing
of the little I don't know they're just
talking do you think the earth is flat
[Music]
believe that he's wearing the Maverick
on it it's like give it you don't have
to brand everything his own suit jacket
that's way too small right you look yeah
it's got a maverick on it and give me a
[ __ ] break bro okay and again he's
I'm still I can't I didn't get over the
drone shot of his house you still there
I don't understand that establishing
location unnecessary flex where's the
drone shot of this elementary school
that's that's how you're established
location so this conversation has taken
place in my seven million dollar mansion
just to let you know so now we're back
at my seven million dollar mansion to
think of this about this even more I
love that he's really gone in deep to
really get to the core of this and by
interviewing a five-year-old an expert
witness or shave his ears yeah
committing uh can I say Indian style is
that that's not he's on applesauce dude
oh nice look at the camera genius I hate
him sorry sorry I shouldn't hate people
I don't hate him but you know what I
hate that he's just so blatantly ripping
off Jane yeah it's just so embarrassing
bro just I don't know man don't try to
pretend like you're a documentarian all
the sudden it's just so transparent he's
like wow Shane's blowing up right now I
gotta do what is this is an appropriate
time to announce that I am working on a
documentary about furries that would be
actually good so that is what I'm
working on and I'm inspired by Logan
Paul it gives me great pleasure to
announce for the 2018 3rd flattered of
international conference this many
people to start questioning the reality
the truth sets you free
[Applause]
stop do you acknowledge that other
planets around I don't know that other
planets are planets this guy had me a
toilet water I don't know what's coming
next but whatever is coming is
groundbreaking bro we don't have toilet
water hey how far do you want me to go
we don't have toilet water flying out on
people in Australia because of grabbity
checkmate don't have that water flying
out at people and on this jail because
of gravity Jack made a Thea can argue
with that
checkmate rounders oh by the way there's
like a cute flat earther that he falls
in love with it's so fake everything is
so fake and apparently his friend is a
flat earth there we're crazy
[Applause]
any organization has to start with their
meetings mush I think we're not crazy
you might have a problem on your hands
Wow he happened to me a supermodel
who believes the earth is flat and
doesn't wear bras either you can see
here a little bit there which isn't what
bras and then there's paparazzi I'll
tell you what is I'll tell you what's
not flat them nips I can see if they
were sure why are you obsessed with it's
not that bad
by the way his henchman is the dumbest
looking guy I've ever seen in my life
okay such a bozo man he just keeps him
around because he makes him feel like a
genius this guy probably got a 800 on
his SAT yeah no sex it down Logan's like
did you trim a girl like that I'll tell
I'll tell her there are this flat
Bobby I just don't know what to believe
anymore truth set you free
well it's that time Logan on a mountain
I can't imagine anything causing I'm
angry enough to smash it what is this
he's trying to see if their world is
curved smashes the globe so the in so
imagine actually like I'm sure that it's
dramatized and he doesn't yeah but being
like yeah I'm a flat earther also why
would you drop the mic that's so douchey
hello what did you see you just like
what you did to a mic drop your dad a
convention this is not an epic victory
imagine doing a mic drop at a flutter
convention does that bother you
yeah all these people are on the same
page [ __ ] you guys but the crowd is on
the same page with him
you don't mic drop at a flat earth
convention it's just not done to the
edge in back I guess assuming I went
there I [ __ ] some hot lady was Flat
Earth I got my nut and then I came back
and I believe the earth is round again
yeah I'm not watching that this is
coming coming out on April 1st early
March 20th next week yeah that's
exciting that is a thrill by the way
Shaq was in hot ones that was just on
her suggestion bars like Hello Shack and
get in my life please for one second I'm
gonna watch that so finally you've been
talking about salt Bay a lot I'm
obsessed with salt Bay because I come to
the realization that he's kind of a
ridiculously gimmicky bad chef the food
he makes is ridiculous
like he'll make he'll cut a piece of a
long stretch of salami he'll cut it in
half Grill it and then dump a bunch of
cheese on it and put it in bread and
he's like dinner served so I saw an
Instagram wouldn't you believe that the
Bradbury's were freaking hanging with
sabe and all that wow this is wait
- this is way too coincidental so here's
the video so I had a quote at support
that is worthy that's very homoerotic I
have to say last time we were saying
what if it was guys would he do the same
move I didn't think so but apparently
it's his thing to feed people at the tip
of a knife and force them into this very
uncomfortable did solve a must be really
psycho to think that people actually
want to do that that's a little gay
right Daniels everyone back that this is
kind of big huge nobody's backing me up
on that
what crickets it's a little gay what's
gay about having a man dangle meat in
front of your face and a tight ass what
are you talking about hi - the tightest
shirt I've ever seen in my life yeah
thank you Dan reminds me of the girl
with Dale Fredo sauce he's basic I mean
he's like yeah deep though this meat by
[Music]
I hate everything about it I just don't
like his persona it's such a dish that's
way too big of a still chewy
oh I know you can't enjoy thank you
forever to chew that it's like a really
expensive cut of meat and he just you're
supposed to eat small bites and enjoy it
I mean my god what the hell look at him
trying to enjoy it yeah well that's it
so I like oh my god this is such a rare
opportunity so we got on the phone with
Ethan Bradberry and Moe Bradbury and we
said when we ask them questions I want
to know how did they enjoy it what was
the experience like so without further
ado we have their answers here for us
today and this is a real treat that real
treat so we asked them first did you
specifically go to meet salt Bay and
this is what they said at the time his
restaurant in New York City just like
opened up and he was gonna be there for
like quite some time maybe a week or two
so we figured it because he's been and
he's a meme and it's like kind of the
whole meme and you know send correlate
so what we do we found an interesting
and intriguing to like she would would
go about in person you know see how he
was in person
give such a long answer usually it's
like a two word man yeah well he's a
meme now I like that he accepted because
when we had them on the podcast it was
like what is a meme I don't understand
and now he's is a meme and he's going
and visiting other memes how did you get
to interact with you oh the way to
interact with that man is you have to
spend a lot of money in his restaurant
yeah either spend over like four or five
hundred dollars then he comes to your
table and does this whole on the little
comedy skit I call it a comedy I love
this car you pay extra to see him well
no he's saying you have to spend a lot
of money and then he'll come through a
little do the meet the old feed you the
meat routine did salt they know who the
Bradbury's were
that would be fascinating like what his
pretty not producer but like one of the
guys the main guy that sells his stuff
and puts it on his social media he
recognized this and he thought it was
cool for him to introduce us to salt bay
and so he introduced us to him before he
they seated us at the table we got to
know him a little for like 5-10 minutes
and then yeah like a whole entourage
that walks around with him like his show
crew or with him the guys that put all
the videos together and kind of like
produce it you know not yet
to be honest he was very quiet he bares
we really talk with him like I do
I was taking a picture with him and then
he just shook my hair was it was mainly
his cameraman I was talking to him
doesn't speak this guy I was these guys
are the best art that I can listen them
talk about anything
salt bass such a weirdo what is this
phenomenon we should try and go no you
wouldn't want to go to sulfates no well
listen them talk about the experience
were they satisfied with their meal
a la carte the New York City you'll find
one every block every every corner block
especially one year in the city like
that was the little tease it was an
appetizer we had like two steaks we had
like lamb chop yeah his salad is the
salad alone is like 35 45 bucks it was
is this like an appetite I felt like you
I ate an appetizer and a an appetizer
still very hungry after that and so like
$5 $5 a la carte plates you know yeah it
was pretty good but if you wanna get
full or if you want to hit the spot you
have to spend I'd say a thousand two
thousand that's not a saying 15 to 20
grand on food the thing is that I've I
mean great like the most expensive
cows in LA which is like Mastro's
Mastro's you can get like the most
ridiculous like aged bone-in filet you
could get a tomahawk let's say which is
like the craziest most expensive for
like 200 bucks and that's enough food
for like three days so I don't know what
was I mean I'm not surprised that he's
charging these insane amounts five
hundred dollars and they weren't even
full doesn't surprise me it does a
little bit and it's packed but here's
the million dollar question that I had
for them was were his elbows clean
because this guy sprinkling salt off his
elbows like that's all good and all
sanitary that's like when you work in a
kitchen
everything's nasty that's why you wash
your hands all the time that's like
having salt on the table where you prep
food and then taking your plate and then
being like scraping it off the table top
on the food so let's see what they said
no I think there was a whole bunch of
like like dry sweat I felt like there
was like you know that was like I felt
like he was sweating thing today in
between what wait didn't he say was
nasty
last time I heard this was covered in
sweat yeah
I thought he said specifically that it
was nasty he did say that in so many
words yeah
what is this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah who's that come from mm it's yeah
another fan
we gotta get anything in mo to talk
about more stuff yeah I like just
hearing them talk about [ __ ] should be
our correspondence h3 podcast correspond
I would love that
love love love love love that I said so
and then they had a special message for
us Eva I haven't heard this one yeah I
so you know we want to congratulate
because we never actually got to do it
verbally so Mia mo want to congratulate
Ethan and ela on their first child thank
you oh that's sweet other guys are
sweethearts on guys like many blessings
you know I know man
I know out of all of the h3 many people
they would have been the last for me to
expect to wind up being actually really
chill and cool guys I don't know cool
it sorry it's hard to say because on one
hand you have to remember they're
they're pranks in the hood yeah but I
guess you know people can redeem
themselves
yeah can grow I've got a Redemption
right sure they're legends I mean what
can you say you got it they're there as
people as complicated and beautiful as
as uh as a look diamonds they are made
in the rough diamonds are made under
intense pressure made under the earth
hmm and so they come out beautiful and I
think the Bradbury's are beautiful
diamonds in that way that it's not
always pretty it's a long process with a
lot of pressure but you come out a
beautiful shining diamond it's beautiful
man thank you
it's really quiet this is Ethan do you
want it so and then that's it that's all
we got that's it that was great we want
to talk about the teddy fresh stuff
we've been going on for like two and a
half hours I won't take long we can talk
about it next week
so next week we have tea oh oh yeah we
have teal Vaughn on Wednesday that I'm
excited about
there was this pot let's just talk about
it I mean I might as well there's this
post and this is always getting posted
so frequently first of all is a fool I
don't know what's their story are they
just like some Chinese knockoff I looked
at their website and everything looks
like a knockoff of some things this pops
up all the time so I thought we'd just
address it yeah yeah it's obviously just
a total knockoff but you can see the
material I think that I will kind of
order one out of curiosity but it's
obviously really shitty fabric and the
thing is that it definitely sucks but I
think it's not that easy to enforce the
trademark or that we have at this point
on like a hoodie it's kind of difficult
and also I'm confident in our quality
and yeah I doc so if you buy this for
$20 it's not gonna be the same you can
see it's like a super lightweight it's
probably disintegrate after one wash but
that's kind of the highest compliment
that we're getting bootlegged I mean
that's pretty sick because if you look
at like supreme or champion or Louie
Vuitton or Gucci or whatever all these
brands the fact that someone actually
cares enough to knock off and boo and I
get ads for this [ __ ] on my Instagram I
like the fact that somebody is worth it
their time to knock us off is kind of
the highest compliment you can really
get for your clothing but so there's
that and then on Ali the part that
actually I really did want to correct
the record on is that this is so typical
of reddit like these reddit geniuses I
think they talked with Ulta
my confidence in their I don't even know
why they I don't know if he erased would
you show the usernames well whatever
it's all public no I guess it's true
it's not like an email address I don't
even know if he well anyway someone
wrote a comment I want to find the Ali
Baba link though well do you guys just
have the link I can find it I think he
may have erased it well anyway Ali Baba
is a Chinese merchant web site it's kind
of like Amazon in China but because it's
in China there's nothing there's
freaking nothing you can do about it and
so there's a lot of merchants on Alibaba
that will rip off popular designs
well they'll actually just rip off the
pictures from our website yeah or
zoomies website and Photoshop out the
logo so they claim that they make it and
so if you want to buy like bulk
quantities they claim that they made the
color block so you can buy from them
yeah it's just it's well this this
commenter he speaks with ultimate
confidence he's like actually Teddy
fresh doesn't even make these they buy
them they're both from Alibaba and
here's the link and it's obvious
Photoshop from zoomies with their logo
photoshopped out and the thing is he
talks so confidently that people just
start uploading they just believe it had
like hundreds of points so I was like
you know I can't I cannot guess I found
one of the comp I don't know if this is
the specific one you were talking about
but it says to everyone claiming the
design is stolen from ela this was
already an existing design that was
incorporated into the petty fresh line
you can buy the sweatshirt in bulk from
Alibaba here which I just gave you that
link yeah so this is literally a picture
from zoomies website so the funny thing
that they photoshopped the logo out of
it couldn't be any further from and
these are all look this has a champion
logo these are all rip designs ripped
here's our other today yeah Ian's
wearing so Ian would you um you can't
stand up yeah there didn't know that
people always want to hear a little bit
about the process so it's kind of I can
explain a little bit now because of this
this accusation
so far from the truth so like with the
color-block hoodie it was about the
fabric itself oh and then some I'm
trying to talk sorry the fabric itself
is first of all custom made it's a
really heavy cotton fabric that is very
unusual for a hoodie usually which we
like that's why we made it that way it's
really heavy really thick and really
like rigid and then the fit is something
that when we start with a design we'll
submit a design to the factory and then
we get a sample and then we do a fit
session when we'll try it on then is
tried our clothing on ian has tried
things on we'll get notes we'll send
them notes and then we'll over a few
samples finalize the fit every time get
a little closer to the fix that we want
takes like half a year the process and
then when you finalize the fit you
finalize the design the callers only
then they make the bulk so that's kind
of like how the process work works so
it's just it's really funny to me that
people I just hate how they speak so
confidently and then and then so people
it started rising up and I like hundreds
of uploads and I'm like you know usually
I don't address this stuff but I think
it's important that especially when
there's so many people out there they're
just looking for a scoop or a story it's
like you can't let the misinformation
become the new fact because we work so
freaking hard on Teddy fresh we have
employed the best people in the business
frankly that we could find I mean
they're like our lead designer that we
love and cherish he works for champion
for like six years I mean he's been in
the business for like 15 years the guy
is incredible talent and and we we went
specifically to get the best people we
could to build this really reputable
company and we spent a lot of time like
you said you know on the fit on the
colors on the sourcing finding factories
to work with these are custom-made ELA
frickin designed this like I just hate I
I really hate reading that and saying oh
oh we buy blanks on Alibaba I'm like
dude
drew this in her notebook I honestly
find amusing if anything just to see
that but then but the lie becomes the
truth yes but so like I even saw people
being like which is so insane they say
no look the pictures on Alibaba is the
same picture on Zoo me so zoomies took
it from Alibaba and put the logo on it
imagine thinking that and people were up
voting I was like 100 up votes imagine
zoomies soomi's there's like a thousand
stores in a mere across the country and
they took a picture from Alibaba this
video will be restocked next week but I
say a lot of people i skim somehow
soomi's magically appeared more pictures
of this model than Alibaba has I don't
know how they pulled that off I even saw
this one with this photoshopped out and
it's like everyone is just so quick to
see the worst and you know it's just we
work so hard on this to make the best
product and we are super proud we stand
by the quality and we stand by the
product and it's just you know and it's
your work it's really it's your this is
really that's why this this stuff don't
even faze me I don't I didn't find it
amusing I don't mind people having their
opinions about the quality and how the
fact but like a blatant lie saying that
we purchased blanks from Alibaba is just
insane I have no idea where you get if
you bought this it's not this there's
just a sullen image I don't even know if
you get anything at all you know but it
from production from you drawing it to
us selling it is like how long's that
take it's like eight months six six
months sometimes longer depending on the
complexity these guys will make it in
seven days apparently so yeah I just
wanted to correct the record on that but
in this case yeah it's just a knockoff I
mean what can you do at least they're
not like
no it's a knockoff it's [ __ ] up and
people always say Oh we'll tell you
fresh didn't invent colors it's like
yeah you can color-block and get tired
I agree sometimes people will send me
stuff as that they think is a copy of
ours and it's not like yes yes total
blocking is something that everyone is
doing totally a lot of stuff and there's
trends and everyone is going with the
trend and everyone is also in art
everyone is inspired from someone else I
I'm usually I'm very open to all this
stuff I don't hold it yeah this specific
metadata Blaine is definitely and direct
I mean it's the same blocking it's the
same colors so I mean you can't really
deny it but again it's not a big deal I
don't actually doesn't bother me that
much it's the misinformation that really
troubled me yeah so that's it but
honestly we've been we just like from
like how we're just hiring our fifth
full-time employee for teddy fresh we
have a project manager a lead designer a
designer we just hired a merchandise er
and we have a I'm bookkeeper and a
bookkeeper and we're looking for graphic
designers yeah yeah we're growing fast
and we are seriously working super hard
and we're we take so much pride and the
product and then in the designs and in
the mint
like so many times we'll get a shirt and
it looks good and it's fine but I'm
obsessed or the fit being perfect then
the quality and the stitching and
everything it's super super super
important for us and we work really hard
and we do not just buy blanks everything
is custom-made custom fit and we have
super talented people working on it
right yeah it's one thing to buy blanks
for a t-shirt you could do that
some people even supreme does that
design just we've never done that we've
we've thought about it but we have never
purchased blanks for a t-shirt yes so
far we haven't but it makes sense in
some cases if you have Ewing our own
original prints or embroidery or
something and you want to make it in the
States there's certain cases we're
buying a blank t-shirt works but that's
a far cry from us cutting so yeah
honey mm-hmm I probably most come
probably most big clothing companies and
street bands I would guess use blanks
for printed tees mm-hmm that's just a
t-shirt and a solid color with a print
on it yeah that's the bread and butter
of a lot of clothing companies so I
wouldn't be surprised if they use blanks
we have never used blanks I'm not saying
we might not I mean it's worth it in
some cases use blanks for t-shirts but
that's besides the point
yeah anything else
next week stuff is finally restoring
yeah the color-block is fine in a while
yeah good we created a black market moon
for some of our clothes I mean that's
incredible right yeah it's insane it's
fluttering yeah and all we have to do is
go to Alibaba and just buy a bunch more
hmm it's the best deal ever yeah it's
super weird that zoomies would just rip
this picture off you'd think they would
take their own pictures being such a
huge cupcake you know so strange it's
like yeah let's get off this almost
three hours all right we're done guys
thanks for watching I hope you all had a
great time
dan is saying wrap it up Dan's over it
no we got to wrap it up Eva probably has
to pee yet I know you're over at Dan
it's fine mm-hmm he said yep
guys it's Friday I thought isn't that
the best I love fresh good hit me with
that music then did and hit me with that
our Kelly one sec then hood then turned
the music yeah we don't want two songs
playing at the same yeah yeah no that
doesn't
it's Friday baby did you get your DVRs
recording did you get your Mexican food
did you get your pizza it's Friday
did you record Seinfeld it's Friday you
can get two for one little caesars no I
don't know it's Friday
Papa Jones was an inside job two miles
Papa John Shatner from his own company
Papa John's kept you pup John with a pup
John it's Friday I hope you all have a
great weekend
thanks for watching
[Music]
I hope you all have a great weekend
thanks for watching good but now I'm
gonna hit it for real did you get your
passport did you get your shots girl
would you like to come back with rubb to
America to America next week we have
Theo von on Wednesday there is a thread
up on the subreddit leave your questions
for him Theo wanted a very hilarious
very incredible chameleon a good old boy
in fact and boys that are honored to
have him on our show he's got his shots
he's got his passports he's ready to go
to America are you guys ready to go to
the weekend I sure AM
thanks for watching and as always stay
awesome well who's that from we always
say that who says stay awesome is that
PewDiePie stay awesome stay awesome guys
stay awesome
got it
[Music]